demonstrators at this pro-palestinian
rally in berlin are angry about the
escalating death toll in the gaza strip
where should the people of gaza go they
ask their anger
directed at the israeli state earlier
this week a similar demonstration was
marred by some protesters using hate
speech against jews
the police are on alert and have said
they will intervene at once
if there are any anti-semitic chants
many pro-palestinian demonstrators say
their message is being overshadowed by
recent reports about anti-semitism
the problem i see in germany is that
more is being said about people being
insulted
then about what we are doing and the
reason for us being here in the first
place
jewish institutions are at higher risk
say the german police
who are taking extra security
precautions as the conflict in gaza
rages on
local rabbi daniel alter feels
anti-semitism is on the rise
he says it's recently become more open
and aggressive
a 17 year old was just here she said she
was on a bus with
friends and was identified as being
jewish
and then insulted they said things like
hitler should have gassed more of you
but the crisis in gaza has also
increased efforts among this group of
jewish and muslim berliners
who want to improve understanding
between these two religious minorities
in germany
trainee rabbi amin langer says it's
important to point out that anti-semites
are a minority
there were about 50 people a loud
minority
using anti-semitic slogans and it's been
covered by the media
everywhere but the danger is not as big
as people think
demonstrators say they'll continue to
protest the israeli army's offensive in
gaza
these are